today's episode is brought to you by
Ridge wallet Ridge wallet it is it's a I
mean it's a damn wallet and you know it
and it's uh you know people will often
they put stuff in their back pockets or
sometimes they'll give a wallet and
they'll make their wife kind of carry
the wallet on their shoulder or
something with like a heavy strap on it
or you know or some people will bury
their wallet and go and get it when they
need it and use money and then ribéry it
and that's all of that [ __ ] is old
that's a bad idea so what you need to do
is get this Ridge wallet and it's that
front pocket carry it's that hard piece
oh listen to this sound
that's me hitting my Ridge wallet with
my fingernails the ridge wallet it's
that front pocket carry and it blocks
out dangerous rays from I mean uh people
trying to steal your identity it'll stop
a damn bullet and that is true I
wouldn't I wouldn't test it out but it
is true and you can go to visit Ridge
wallet comm slash theö th EO and use the
code théo at checkout for 10%
that's code théo for 10% off at Ridge
wallet dot-com
it's that front pocket carry baby and
you got a you got to have that specialty
piece oh man I am that Saints game and
well let's get into it
you
ah just a somber way a sombre way to
move in to the day
Sariah you know want to lift you up but
the Saints game it just it evac part of
me just evaporating when they lost I
mean it was like someone yeah I mean it
was like someone you know just
emancipated part of my soul it was like
they you know it was like it was like
you know like that song like take add
take another little piece of my heart
now baby man it was like somebody just
plucked the dammit a aorta right out of
my chest and just made a damn may order
gravy right in front of me and drank it
it was like somebody just drank a one of
my favorite pieces of my heart it was a
tough one man that was a tough loss and
and you know they had to call I'm
talking about the Saints in Rams game
and kudos to the Rams you know but not
really but also God you I knew it was a
tough one when afterwards none none of
my friends even wanted to say anything
on the phone
we couldn't even talk I mean you know
the Saints lost last year on that
miracle play on that million-dollar
miracle and and that was man that won
that was heavy but that happened you
know and that was the day bad defense
poor tackling and then this one though
they were supposed to be there and some
things in happen I think in life are
supposed to happen they're just supposed
to it is destiny and it was supposed to
be Brees versus Brady in the Super Bowl
this is gonna be the worst most watched
Super Bowl ever even
babe even babies that were supposed to
you know be born a month from now they
were gonna come out early you'd see an
early you you'd see an early baby like
damn that baby that that thing's [ __ ]
premature but it uh it loves football
you know babies were gonna come out of
the womb early to see these two bad boys
go at it Brees and Brady Brady and Brees
and and that's what that's what the the
that's what the universe wanted that's
what the universe said here you go
Saints here you here some opportunities
here's some opportunities and and look a
lot of people want to talk about that
call the pass interference unbelievable
even more though the helmet to helmet
was the thing that got me really just
felt like somebody just hit a bunch of
just damn pop rocks
you know just deep inside of my ass and
uh man it just it was just insane I mean
you could hear the helmet you could hear
it at home but that but but also the
Saints had a part in it and I've said
this for years
Sean Payton too much ego man
all those men work that hard to get into
that opportunity and it's the Saints
have the balls with two minutes left and
they're in the Rams territory you run it
you just keep running it man
the Rams have to use their timeouts and
you give them the ball back with maybe
20 seconds left or whatever or a minute
left and they have to go the whole field
it just and your step and you're gonna
get your field goal it just seemed like
he you know he tried to run too many
things but Taysom Hill what do you I
like I love Taysom Hill but you have
Drew Brees brother Drew Brees is the you
know if Jesus Christ ever had an
appendix and they took the appendix out
of his body and it just
showed up here on earth and just started
just dropping dimes to people in the
distance that's drew brees drew brees is
the 11th finger of Christ brother and
then not have him out there and you
trying these cutesy [ __ ]
just I mean in some painter sitting over
there he got that booty in his mouth if
you look at Sean Payton's his mouth like
a damn booty hole like a bee hole sorry
and I didn't mean to say that but like a
bee oh and God why I mean that if he
doesn't have to be cute there if he
don't have to be fancy even if he
doesn't do all that the saints when they
rot but but when you too much ego and I
don't make destiny it'll make destiny
say wow this guy don't want to be a part
of everything he wants to do he wants to
be cutesy he wants to be faint t he
wants to be faint say boy fancy boy and
that's the thing and it hurts and people
say well you're not a Saints fan if you
say that kind of stuff man don't say
that [ __ ] to me I am a fan brother I
mean I it's just it's hard it's hard you
know now immediately I think of the you
know a lot of senior citizens and
they're gonna die in the next year they
don't even get to see the opportunity
for the next season and this was
something they you know just a lot of
full hearts ah you know he's gonna give
them that opportunity to roll up into
heaven with a little bit a little extra
[ __ ] you know chowder and they're in
their bowl a little extra spirit chowder
in their soul Bowl and man it just oh
it's just heartbreaking and I couldn't
could not even bear to talk to some of
my friends man one buddy I called him we
sat down the phone and we couldn't even
talk and you know it just uh it just
goes like that sometimes but but being a
fan is hard isn't it I was thinking
about that being a fan because you want
something so bad but you have no control
over it
you know you but you put a lot into it
you put time in you show up and watch
the games you get you a little you know
a flag or maybe some you know a little
uh maybe shoes for the baby that have
you know little um Tennessee Titans on
them or whatever you want whatever your
team is you know Brooklyn ah I don't
know what that team is up there [ __ ]
I think it's just a bunch of rappers and
people with guns really about Brooklyn
Nets you know you get you spend you
invest you care you read the articles
you know you stay up late and you go to
your favorite reporter you go to his
Twitter timeline and see what he dropped
after the game you know you mourn the
loss when you know your mom Bushrod lost
his child you think about that during
the day you know you think about that
and you you pray for him or you think
about him and you hope that he finds
strength to continue his season and to
keep his you know just find strength for
his family and you know you just think
about a lot of these different things
and it you care and you're there and you
want them and you see their joy and you
see and then it just I just felt like
Sean Payton a coach that way seems
selfish because you got a lot of people
whose lives are can be affected by this
moment of joy and I love my Saints I'm a
Saints fan but I think that they were
supposed to win that game
and even with the call like that that's
destiny again saying look here's the
passenger and the refs [ __ ] that up
they missed that so deaf I you know I
put it half on the referees and I bet I
put half of it on on on coach Payton I
really do man you know him well
homeward bro homeward but man I was
trying to go to this dude I was driving
here was the thing I came up I was in
Irvine this weekend and thank you to
everyone that came out this young lady
showed up and she'd drawn a a beautiful
damn picture of me and I was like god I
should have been a piece of art cuz I'm
I look better as a damn drawing you know
I'm really that you know two-dimensional
let's [ __ ] do it
when I get in a third dimensional you
know like I am now that's when you know
things get a little not as attractive
but she showed me you know it was just a
stent it what does that call it a little
thing that you used to like show people
stuff with them it's like from the 7
[ __ ] pencil she had up she was like
pencil and she did it and it was
beautiful and she brought it out and
what else some man brought out some you
know some toilet spray for when you in
the toilet and I still got to look at
that stuff and then what else oh a nice
gift somebody brought me out a nice pin
but man we had some fun we had some fun
did I tried a couple jokes I've never
tried before one about some fires I
don't know if I should have done it but
but man I tried my best
the Saturday early show was kind of dead
I don't know what was going on it could
have been me I don't know but that
Sunday show was way go man that's Sunday
show and I needed it you know I'm so
grateful because I needed I needed that
dude driving the Irvine man I was almost
in tears in my car man it just made me
mad that Saints loss it just you know
when I driven back to LA the night
before
my friend had a going-away party that
was eating breakfast and then going away
and damn and I just meant I was I was in
the column and I was just so just I was
just disheartened I thought the whole
world was gonna fall apart I've started
feeling just down about myself man I was
just it was just kind of a lot of
emotions I mean it had been an emotional
week because I get into these shows man
when I do my shows you know I get into
it I want to you know I you know I want
us to have an experience and then and
then that said this that letdown man it
felt like there was a like there was
destiny in the world and then destiny
got shook out of place and that can
happen man I just you know I was I was
so angry before the pass interference
because of the some of the coaching I
mean just play calling crazy just
pointless I don't see how Brees doesn't
say hey this isn't a good play to call
right now but you know what I'm not a
coach hell I'm not even a player dude
I'm not even I mean I let my legs and my
butt got tight like yesterday for no
reason so I'm not even I'm not even a
waterboy but but I'm a fan you know and
being a fan you put so much out what do
you think about being a fan I'd love to
know some of you guys has thoughts and
just on what it is to be a fan and what
goes into it and what because here's one
thing I thought I thought this at the
end of the game I said when I was
driving down to Irvine I thought to
myself I said well man if this is the
type of refereeing they're gonna have in
the games and if this is the type of you
know coaches can just call horrible [ __ ]
and and it can break your damn heart
like I don't know if I want to watch as
much or get as deep it as I do anymore
because
as a fan because the other side of the
equation they're not you know I felt
like the coach didn't do his part in the
refs didn't do their part to make it a
fair fair enough field for me to put my
emotions into it that's what I felt like
so if you guys have thoughts on what it
is to be a fan and and what that means
to you or if you had a family member
that you know what gave it there you
know just I mean some people cuz I'll
never play you know I'll never there was
a point in my life when I'd be like oh I
might get out there and play you know
I'd be sitting on the couch at 27 you
know you know getting a couple of grams
of freaking on that that dusty dusty
that dusty Dusty dusty and then uh next
thing you know I'm thinking in my head
oh I might get out there and play next
year I might try to audition for the New
Orleans Saints that was the kind of the
LSU you know I'm saying things would be
in my head I'm all first of all my
buddy's like dude you're gonna audition
for the team it's called trying out
you're an idiot
do you go out there and audition you're
gonna get sent to all heaven bruh
somebody is gonna break your spine open
with a straight spine buster dude so
yeah it is but if you have thoughts on
what it means to be a fan and what it
just mean it was just so painful it felt
like part of me just was so alive and
then it was gone like it was oh it was
just gone but thank you guys for being
here with me today man I am dude I
couldn't even do the podcast yesterday I
was so upset but I'm just so grateful to
cuz I got on stage and you know I was
about to go on stage and I was just not
in a good mood and then I did a
meditation backstage for ten minutes you
know I just sat there and just shut it
all down and put the timer on my phone
just crossed my legs and just closed my
eyes in the greenroom and asked
everybody else to leave out of there for
a few minutes and yeah for ten minutes
out of sat there and just let all the
things pass that were making me up
at or whatever and they disappeared
kinda and then I got on stage man and
you know it's really a nice gift from
the powers that be in the world because
I needed to have something fun to lift
me up and 500 people lost Sunday night
at Irvine did exactly that and man that
was fun I had so much fun so thank you
guys for coming out
I will what else happened man oh so I
got a UH I got a full body one of those
full body massage those thigh massages
or no from ladies from ma Taiwan and I
went in there and got that Dai massage
and dude they walk on your back I mean
this is this lady it look like she was
loitering and I was the sidewalk this
baby's bad [ __ ] was up and down the
block you know and she had I mean she
had real heavy feet
she was real you know cementy in the in
the footage and she just plopped them
bad cats on me and it felt like a real
if she felt like a about a 50 year old
man kind of walking up and down my back
but it was probably about she was
probably got 42 43 but heavy feet I mean
real heavy tarsals probably the bone
density and her feet could have been a
damn category 6 bruh so but at the end
dude so she got me on you know she doing
my thighs and stuff and I'm late on my
back and that's in a you know I'm kind
of vulnerable I'm laying there kind of
vulnerable in us and she kind of Pat's
me on the cross on their freaking I'm a
little Rokit you know she just does like
this just Pat's me on my little rocket
and asked me if I want that you know
that that party pop you know I'm saying
she was Sher Singh from what that part
that party Pop's she said but you know
she had thought she had died accent she
said oh you won't they on the party pump
I don't like Diane you know and I said
no I said I don't want that I said I
don't want that you know I'm trying not
to masturbate myself and you I'm coming
in here my back's all tightened up I got
the ass of like a my butters gets tight
you know my thighs get tight my thighs
get tight tight tight you know like a
damn like kind of I got that ass cheek
of like a you know black girl with Down
syndrome who's been dude playing twister
by herself you know my thighs get
[ __ ] just you know real tight tight
because I got that booty and a man she
wanted to give me that you know that
little that party pop and uh and I said
no and that's my thing usually I go when
I go into these places these look you
know the the thigh massages when I go in
there and they trying to you know they
trying to you know get you to spray out
an earring in the jack Shack and one of
my buddies said they'd yer come off
sometime and they left with the semen
you believe that [ __ ] they put that [ __ ]
on a little hot plate or a little
griddle brought a little grill and they
next thing you know you got a damn
family over there
you got a dang little you know you got a
little couple of little batch of whites
or you know Latino you know you got a
little family running around and you
know in Kuala Lumpur
so that's wow that's the new thing they
jerk you often and they cop that scene
and I'm not saying these women are bad
women or anything like that I mean you
know seven out of out of probably seven
out of probably thirteen times I go into
one of these massage parlors and they do
it right and they do that choppy choppy
on daddy and they [ __ ] dude they used
to have these people are told Jim
Jefferies is downtown you for $40 these
two Vietnamese dudes will [ __ ] beat
the [ __ ] out of you
and they had saw arms and hands but also
like fast and soft and it just and it
felt good and if you like damn bruh
these dudes were [ __ ] but goddamn
there's really do a great job I feel so
much better what else is going on and
pop into the news oh I saw this I
thought this was interesting in the USA
today they had you know they had some
fellas they had a big you know these
rallies and these marches and stuff and
but I thought that USA Today did a good
job today and I shared this on Twitter a
new video shows different side of
protests with a Native American and
Native Americans those are the original
bad boys' they get those guys were out
it you know this was their country you
know they were here they just really
sprouted up out of the damn earth I mean
they are just like birch they're just
like roses they're just like ferns you
know I mean they're humans I'm saying
but they are as natural as that you know
it's almost like a stream just you know
he's just going through the land and the
stream and the land got enough friction
and next thing you know you boy kielbasa
popped out with a you know with a la he
and he was just of the land and he was
just of the nature and that was a Native
American and he was a natural boy and
anyway they had this conflict where it
was like these guys from Kentucky school
and and everybody jumped on the
bandwagon of saying that these kids were
awful and these kids were horrible and
because only a small piece of a video
had gone out where a Native American man
and a group of um what does it say black
Israelite guys and and these white
Catholic kids that all kind of merged in
this area and only a small piece of the
video had gone out and and everybody
just had we all had conclusions we all
had thoughts we all had this and that
you know and and then USA Today I
thought I did a good job of just saying
well this is the full thing a
video came out and this is the reality
of what happened and it seemed like
everybody there definitely could have
made probably some better choices but it
seemed like the kid that they were
trying specifically to pin this on was
maybe the least the least guilty of
being to erroneous I mean for one he's
very young and the other people involved
in the kind of exact conflict were a
little bit older but I say this too
tight said the reason I brought this up
is because that's one of the value of
our podcasts is that you can get the
whole breadth of what's going on and and
I just want to thank people that come
and listen and that listen to other
podcasts because you don't just get a
little snip you don't just get three or
four seconds or 40 seconds of exactly
what the writer or the creator wants you
to see what they want you to believe you
get the full story and when you go back
and see the full story you see that some
of these other groups
we're causing a lot more trouble than
this young boy and in fact the the black
Israelite group was really was raised
just raising sheer hell and then and
look they all have their points of view
and all points of view you know valid
not saying that but but just what I'm
saying is just that when you see the
breadth of the video you see it all you
get the reality at least then you can
see you can take everything into account
so I thought that that was least USA
Today made a point to say hey here's the
full story and you don't see that very
often and that's one thing I like about
podcasting you get that full story you
get that FS but yeah there's just more
value if we can know the full story of
things because you get the perspective
you get it all you get what was
happening before what the build-up was
what occurred what was you know you get
you get it all and you can
an educated decision or an educated idea
or also you see everybody's part in
something it's the same as with the with
the if you just look at the pass
interference call from the Saints Rams
games Saints Ram game you know which
probably killed I'd love to see an
article on how many people died when the
pass interference call didn't get called
I bet is there an over/under on that I
bet eleven people died
I bet eleven seniors just took it right
in that straight [ __ ] tick-tock her
dog in that HEA Artie Poppa and just
said [ __ ] it son life ain't what I
thought it was I'm going to have on and
but you but if you watch that whole game
you see all of it you get the whole game
you see okay well they had some
opportunities here and they you know
they you know the they had their back
uptight in in the beginning of the game
and he missed the path and you just you
see all you see all of the things that I
went along the way you see the coach oh
the coach made these decisions man he
could have made better decisions he
could have not been cute you see that so
you don't just get that moment you get
the full story and that's one of the
beauties of podcasting is you could sit
and listen to a lot of people and get
the full story and I believe that
there's you know there's people that
want to serve the short story to get
their point across and theirs and theirs
and podcasting that's why it's taken off
is because it it just gives you the full
story and lets you make your own choices
I don't feel like it's trying to
convince you of things very much but
also what the [ __ ] do I know man you
know just a sad dude that drove down to
Irvine last night and got lifted up by
about 500 people and in turn had maybe
the best show of the weekend I thought
so
what else is going on let's get into
some of this man I want to tell you that
I'm going to be in in Columbus Ohio next
weekend I've also got Tempe Arizona the
tickets for Australia will be going on
sale in February I think they go and
sell February 11th I don't know the
cities yet but I think it's most of them
we're gonna do another show in Boston at
the Borgata and you can check that bad
cat out and that's Beantown they say
over there Boston dude and everybody
embossed and brought us freckles
that's freckle country you can get
freckles over there so February 22nd
through February 23rd I'll be in Houston
March 8th the Wilbur in Boston we're
adding another show and then I'm in San
Jose and in Phoenix Arizona and Kansas
City Missouri through March and April so
pretty exciting pretty exciting stuff
going on and thank you guys for your
support we sold it out in Irvine we sold
it out and I want to thank Martin Luther
King as well you know what just a great
speaker a leader and I can only imagine
the confidence that he had a lot of
times to really stay in the face of
adversity and trust himself you know
even probably when his people some
people were following him that he didn't
he might have thought were followers for
have him for the wrong reason a lot of
people attached to Martin Luther King
you know when somebody starts to be a
leader people attached to them and some
of those attachments are good and
helpful and teammates and some are want
to take and they want to just you know
they want something for themselves but
you know he really seemed to be I mean
he was just so poignant so eloquent you
know last night I stayed up I was
watching a couple of different speeches
and and parts from different
documentaries that were on YouTube and
just such an eloquent man you know
there's a real
mastery to being able to get your point
across exactly how you want it it's one
of the reasons I which had a bigger
vocabulary sometime but thank you to him
because if just little things like even
for me I wouldn't been able to have a
Sunday night's show that had so many
people come out because a lot of people
have the day off today
and thank you Martin Luther King because
jr. because you knew that I would need
the day off after that [ __ ] referee
call [ __ ] and that is [ __ ] so and that
is straight B hole and I will say that
now behold if you love sex
you're gonna love blue Chu it's that
time baby
look I said this years ago that I said
look man one of these sexual pills they
should make a gum they should make that
bubblegum that way you could be at the
Barbie in the distance
chew a couple pieces blow that big
bubble big bubble let the ladies see
that [ __ ] bad bounce boy in the
distance flying out of your [ __ ] flow
state air face and they'd be like oh
dang that boy got that big bubble going
in the distance and they know daddy's
ready to pop pop you know daddy's ready
to freaking bust out them you know them
body oysters you know what I'm talking
about
cinnamon you know body semen so blue Chu
has it blue chew is a performance
enhancement for the bedroom
would you like to last longer go extra
rounds I don't want to go extra rounds I
want to go one round and as long as one
of us kind of wins and one of us [ __ ]
we can even both lose one of my new
things that I'm gonna start doing
probably in the next couple years is no
more even ejaculation you want that you
got to pay extra you want that pop pop
cuz I know that a lot of these ladies
sneaking a they putting that thing on it
they putting that sauce on a warming
plate and busting it out the backdoor
shipping it off to Guam or Germany or
probably you know New Jersey or
Bethlehem or something and they pop it
you know and they slanging that the
sugar sauce on the DL
getting them height in prices for
daddy's pop-pop but what I'm trying to
tell you guys is a sorry I can't get
through this ad blue chew is a
performance enhancement for the bedroom
you know uh you know I've had issues
over the years and I used to get them
gas station wiener pills and I used to
get them gas station wiener pills and
I'm not ashamed man
people say you ashamed of that I ain't
ashamed that you think I'm ashamed that
now I would sometime I will say this I
would buy all kind of extra [ __ ] at the
7-eleven to try and make it look like I
wasn't getting those like I get like a
um you know a couple bananas a gas can I
get nervous I'm like a six scratchers
you know and now I and uh you know maybe
a thing I'll Minh milk and then let me
get them um you know them rhinoceros
Silver's and he's like huh and the guy
was like what what is it and the guy
wasn't a different at this he was just a
white guy who couldn't speak well and
he's like what what is it and I'm gonna
let me get them the Rhino Silver's boy
let me get them [ __ ] giraffe makers
you feel me
then gas station wiener pills daddy you
know it you know what I'm talking about
I need two gallons of gas and some
[ __ ] and you know and I need about
two grams that I run at that silver
rhino down in in a nut tank I need I
need two gallons of 91 octane and I need
40 milligrams of that silver rhino down
in a nut tank and look a lot of that
[ __ ] didn't make your leg sweat and then
you're bought your your a right your
your wiener will get hard out of fear
your wieners like damn the legs are
sweating something's going on you know
what if the legs aren't gonna work and
the wieners is probably thinking I might
have to become a leg or something I
might have to walk for us so that's when
the wiener gets hard but anyway blue
chewed calm makes the first chewable
with the same active ingredients as
Viagra and Cialis and it a lot lower
price in those other two chewables work
faster than pills up to twice as fast
it only takes a few minutes to fill out
a form online no doctor visit no awkward
conversation you don't have to set your
soft you know CAC and if somebody you
know into a nurses hand like a it's so
soft you know she's like oh what do you
use on that downy dryer sheets it's like
nah just got a lot of anxiety and some
mental health and sexual health issues
so I don't get erections but but no
waiting in line at a pharmacy it ships
directly to your door in discreet
packaging and I've seen it they do some
unique packaging they'll do they'll put
it in like a um what is that thing is
you beat up if you're Mexican not if
you're if you're you know you beat it
and you and you and you you know kind of
you get it and you [ __ ] what am I
talking about and you blonde and you
[ __ ] blindfold and you [ __ ] beat
him pinata
sorry pinata and they got them sugar
treats in it and that is what you that's
what it's like
what was that talking about oh no
waiting in line at the pharmacy ships
directly Rohingyas discreet packaging
sometime they'll ship it in a discreet
package she'll get it in like a pinata
kind of thing and like a little donkey
like a little for colored donkey and you
think oh what's in here and you got them
straight-up [ __ ] deep hills son you
know them [ __ ] form makers bruh
but anyway ships directly your door blue
chewables are prescribed online by a
doctor and made in the USA no more tees
you know I get that used to get them
shits from India bruh then things come
in and they used to make my hair get
real warm which was very imagine your
hair being warm and that's when you know
them them erection pills are working
when your hair starts the temperature
your hair starts heating up blue 2 gives
you confidence in bed every time you and
your partner will love it
here's a great deal for you guys for our
listeners get out there and get [ __ ]
healthy go to blue qu b lu e CH e w calm
get your first order free when you use
promo code Theo th EO you just pay $5
for the shipping that's blue
chu dot-com and promo code Theo get them
vasodilator hitters bro get them Wiener
hitters ah you know I've had issues over
the years with that sexual issues god I
got so many issues but but I'm seeing a
sponsor I got a new sponsor you know I
know we talked about some of that in the
past and I'm happy to be having that
right now and trying to get through
someone more my program step work and
you know my life is pretty good man you
know my life is pretty good I was just
thinking about that bro you know I was
just thinking I think part of the reason
I was even sad like I was driving down
in the game and driving down to the show
yesterday and I was sad after the loss
man I was really heartbroken but I think
some would just you know so many people
came out and it's just exciting and I
just I think part of me there's a fear
that I'm not going to be able to you
know make people laugh for you know or
I'm not gonna like live up to like
people's expectations you know and
and you know I couldn't really figure
out what the feeling I was having
yesterday when I was driving down there
but I guess it was like okay I'm feeling
kind of bad right now after the game you
know I messed up and I hadn't taken my
little you know antidepressants you know
for a day and so maybe that started to
factor in like I well what if you start
and you know he's reeling a little he's
starting to lose his grip on the
mountain oh do you know what touch and
so that was kind of going on and so then
when the fear that when they thought
that man maybe I was like wow if my
feelings aren't if I don't keep myself
in a healthy place then what if I get on
stage and I just make people it's not
good you know I'm not able to do my job
or people don't like it I think I just
got a lot of fear because when nobody
when you know when people didn't come to
the shows as much for years you you kind
of earned like honestly it's kind of a
sweets it's just kind of a sweet spot
because you don't have to the
expectation isn't there you have the
ability to surprise people you know when
you have a when you're able to do
something and people don't know it it
must be like a magician they know the
person doesn't know the magic they know
the person didn't go to magic class or
you know or [ __ ] abracadabra camp or
you know wasn't in like a trap house
where one of the hookers or you know one
of the drug dealers was [ __ ] you know
pulling rabbits out of a hat and that
but it must be like a magician because
they know they can do the trick they
know it's probably they know how to do
it and they know the person is gonna be
surprised and that's what it used to
seem like a lot of clubs it was like
okay you know the shows weren't sold out
and there weren't and I was like oh okay
you know I'm gonna be able to surprise
these people with
my humor or with a story or with
something that they don't know and and
then now it's just a little different
now I guess it's just more xpect it's
more expectation like now they're here
and they know that you can do it or they
hope that you can do it so I guess it's
just it's just adjustment you know I
mean I'm just kind of trying to share
just like candidly like some of my fears
and stuff but it's just adjustment you
know before it was like okay I you know
I know that I can do this I'm gonna
Surprise them it'll be a magic trick but
now it's like okay they're they're
assuming that I'm going to be able to do
this and so now I have to be able to do
it and it's uh and it's great it's just
different it's just different and then I
saw I guess I was worrying when I was
driving down there I was like man if I'm
what if some time I'm feeling bad I'm
not you know and I don't get it all
lined up and stuff and the show doesn't
go as well and and I'll let people down
you know and I know they say you know
and we say it's not supposed to matter
what other people think and and you know
I and and I'm sure that's one of my
character defects is wondering what
people think a lot or I mean so much in
my life I was just living I just needed
to make people laugh so that I knew that
they were okay with me you know because
I think inside of me I just you know I
didn't like myself so much that I needed
them to I needed their approval because
it was the only place I got any approval
was from just moments of strangers just
little pieces of just moments of
approval that would just fly by like a
shooting star Amanda there we go so
little there go
there goes a little and I need more and
I need more approval I just and I didn't
think walk around thinking I needed it I
just needed it you know it was like you
know it was like part of my I think
approval is what makes up part of your
comfort zone and that approval a lot of
times is you know your parents will
teach you how how to approve yourself or
you will you know where someone at
school will teach you and when you don't
get some of those lessons and you don't
know and so then you have to get it from
extemporaneous places from outsiders
brought from straight up SE Hinton's you
feel me you got to get it from you know
from this stranger this person you have
to get that approval and you know as
much as it is that you want the approval
I thinking now more it is just that I
want people to feel good you know I want
to be able to make people happy and I
want to be able to make people laugh man
they had a young guy came out and his
son and his dad and and and they'd never
been to a comedy show before and that
was so rare we had a couple vietze come
out dude 100% real vs man and they came
out there and I didn't eat any of them
because you guys know I had that
instance at a Best Buy four years ago
we're almost snacked into that boy and
his name was Ben but that's because I
was on the cleanse on a cleanse and I
hadn't eaten anything in a while and got
a name brother I'm gonna keep taking a
good hard look at V yet but they are
[ __ ] damn near delectable beautiful
humans so if I die do it at my and a
couple of other vietze die with me we
all die together you know maybe we're at
like a prom you know like a Viet prom
and something happens as a fire at the
prom and we all die do bury me with them
tasty Viet son that's my squad
but I'm just it's sorry I'm trying I'm
getting off track but you know if you
get those those pieces of approval make
you feel okay and you have some people
you have a built in you don't have a
built in you then you have this you have
to find you have to find moments that
make you okay oh I need some okay from
over here I need some okay okay I need
this I okay okay and but now yeah it's
not as much that is I just want to be
able to be in a healthiest place to be
able to to make the show good and make
it fun for people and also I know that a
lot of mountings are so understanding
and cool and man so many nice people so
many nice people couple came out they're
about to have their third kid that was
beautiful
somebody came out their friend bailed on
him and they still showed up man that
was nice man you know I don't know if I
would do that for people but maybe now I
will you know it's funny the things that
I learned from even people that come out
to the shows pretty you know mr. Lawson
I'm a pretty lucky guy to you know not
only am I getting to have people come
and listen to my art but I'm getting to
meet a lot of really neat people so just
thank you thank you everyone that came
out thank you the people I got to meet
thank you the people that I did not get
to meet and I hope to meet you next time
what else I'll tell you this man this
past weekend is brought to you by
Skillshare a lot of people have any
skills dude think about them think about
somebody right now this dude I know
named Kenneth bra this is this is zero
skills dude he's TB in his front yard
all the time in a damn my sleeping bag
and you go over there and wake him up or
something and he'd be in there eating
little gummy worms or something cuz his
daddy did the uh would restock those
chips those Tom's chips and stuff at the
gas at the vending machines you know in
a vending machine is basically just a
bunch of straight [ __ ] locked in a
cage and you got to put money in there
and and this boy would just be laying up
and he's [ __ ] lazy as [ __ ] man and
he'd be laying up in that in that
sleeping bag and he you know he'd always
be an extra little snacks his daddy had
from the Tom's route you know a little
so maybe got some snack of bugles or you
know some gummy worms or sometimes you
see them [ __ ] he'd be having like
some Fritos but also some gum at the
same time like what the [ __ ] bro do you
need to read like an appetite chart or
something you need to know how a damn
how appetite stacks up because you can't
be having [ __ ] juicy fruit barbeque
chip going on in your mouth at once
that'll change how time works man you
got to [ __ ] shut that [ __ ] down
that's the dark arts brother but
Skillshare is a place where you can get
a skill if you have a friend or neighbor
even yourself
that's laying in a yard and a sleeping
bag and snacking on gummies then change
your life Skillshare is an online
learning community for creators with
more than 25,000 classes and design
business and more you discover you'll
discover countless ways to fuel your
curiosity creativity and career at
Skillshare you can take classes in
social media marketing mobile
photography creative writing or even
illustration look if you don't think if
you're sitting at home you're thinking
man I want to make dope ass art I want
to do trap music [ __ ] but on my phone I
want to have that next thing I want to
be there's a company called bleach Media
official you see him a lot of times on
Instagram bleach media official they
make really cool thing they started put
the guy just figured out how to do some
[ __ ] and got on board and started making
free [ __ ] for people that he loved and
now people are paying them to do stuff
you can make you can make the change and
I do believe this I'm not just saying
this
I believe this Skillshare is a place
that can help you you can join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for our listeners get 2 months of
Skillshare for free that's right
Skillshare is offering this past weekend
listeners two months of unlimited access
to over 25,000 classes for
free to sign up go to Skillshare calm
slash Theo von
again go to Skillshare calm slash Theo
von to start your two months now that
Skillshare calm slash Theo von and I'm
trying to come to England in August so
we it's not locked out and maybe Eastern
Europe that Eastern Bloc but we'll see
but man I'm a pretty lucky guy you know
and I don't mean to sound like I'm not
lucky at all I'm not grateful but I know
sometimes like it kind of you know down
or about stuff and but man it's just
been a wild ride you know and this has
just been a wild ride and uh and it's
scary it's exciting but it's also really
scary you know it's it's scary uh you
know it's scary sometimes you know
sometimes I put myself out there in some
ways even on this podcast and things and
then you know it's just uh it's I don't
know it's okay but it's just scary
sometimes and I don't know life
sometimes just a little spooky man I
mean they call it life but sometime they
should just call it Halloween okay let's
get into some of you guys as calls right
now here we go the red from salted AE
let me catch your name again cat daddy
because I think I missed a UH one of
them Salah bowls baby safety oh the red
from childhood this is red alright red
homework South Carolina um the one
that's going to the Navy I just I'll
listen to your uh oh yeah brother you're
going into the Navy I remember that and
when is that happening let's hear more
the podcast where you please where you
played my message sorry bad you got me
you really got to turn up dead I'll
leave tomorrow to this today is Sunday
January 20 2008 tomorrow
this is really hit hold now and I'll
yeah I want to look like a [ __ ] from
your podcast everything but bro nobody
could ever look like more of a [ __ ] on
this podcast ma duck that's sweetie just
say I want to hear more your message
brother homeward this just you're so
kind
thank you for your advance and uh come
January I'll call I'll call back yes
Melissa y'all catch up with them
semester so that way I don't walk upon
and I'll definitely call you that I just
want to thank you that really bit a lot
to me that but uh gay gay ban gang gang
man that's sweetie to call brah that's
really touching me you made me feel good
or you made me feel something my sons
don't even know what it is man so you
got me tearing up so yeah you couldn't
look like any more of a punkin me man
because if one dude tears up that's you
know that's pretty regular but then the
dude that tears up hearing the other do
tear up that's that dude I'm that dude
right now well that's nice of you to say
that man you know you know I you know
I'm trying to think what's got me kind
of feeling a little bit any Moda man I
think I'm happy to know that you know
that uh that people care you know and
that someone cares and I don't care that
that person is me or that that person is
our listeners or I'm just happy because
I could tell in your voice that you seem
like you know that and uh and wouldn't
you say you leave him
I'm just happy yeah well let's call him
and maybe I can
yeah I got this technology here let's
call let's call big red man and see if
he's gonna fight for us you know we're
going up I mean that's a big trip that's
brave too man I could imagine that let's
well what am I sitting here imagining
when we got freakin real technology
let's hit him up right here mmm we got
his number right here we go hello he is
red there this is Oh what's up playboy
is Theo
yeah player what's up dude we I just was
listening your call man and I just
wanted to thank you so much for reaching
out bro I was really really nice to you
and you said that you're going today's
the 21st you're going into boot camp
today oh nice man that's wild she
already said your goodbyes to the wife
and kid Oh huh yeah man I bet and in
your is it a daughter or a son you got a
daughter a little girl yes sir oh wow
how old is she she's eyes oh well I
appreciate you calling man it was nice
you know you know you you know when you
called last week and said you know that
you're listening to the podcast they're
just nice of you and and then you're
like yeah your way it's gonna keep you
posted and yeah and then you call back
man it was just it was just nice of you
but you know I think it kind of embodies
some of the stuff that we think about
here a lot and stuff like that so you're
what you said about my message yesterday
it really at me and I was in my emotions
a lot yesterday and it really had me
work done I just want to tell you thank
you for that it was extremely kind of
you oh that's nice here to say man
I mean look nobody's for I mean
I've gotten in my motion so many times
in this podcast you know I'm sure I'm on
some [ __ ] helpless since I'm on a lot
of probably prayer lists and stuff like
that so nobody could out emo me on here
but and plus I cried for about an hour
in my car after the Saints lost
yesterday so I don't think about you and
mr. Kreischer oh yeah what an [ __ ]
no that's a good pair man Bert's an
amazing guy so tell me about um so tell
me about why'd you choose to go into the
Navy like what's like some of the
thoughts behind that I was due to uh
education I couldn't mm-hmm I had just a
GED and a UH May of last year they
called me and said that things had
changed that with a GED I was able
eligible to join I just had a score a
certain number on the ASVAB to join and
I made the number and I just lost the
weight I was a 250 pounds in May yeah I
don't know one night damn bruh so I
could be here today dude that's not like
a turkey that is like a turkey to an
hour bruh I was a real lean you know if
you've ever had a lure not yeah well
Al's definitely more of a limited meat
but it's more I mean if dude if you take
the feathers off a now they look like
they're ready to [ __ ] fight bro so
they're pretty jacked they look real
Italian owls might be Italian but dude
that's amazing man so you just decided
you were gonna get in there and when
they called you back at first we did you
like were you excited were you
considering really you know at first or
what what was that like it was a I told
the guy that called me ask my wife I
can't go through this did not let her be
involved with with the process she
supported me from the get-go you know
she knew it was gonna be a struggle just
with the weight and trying to manage you
know a full-time job losing weight and
trying to make it here I'm here today
and I'm glad of it dude it's almost like
it's like a like yeah with that weight
loss and then now you getting there it's
like you must feel kind of proud of
yourself too I
there's 77 guys here today this hotel
with me not all from the Navy just were
all over different branches and I'm glad
to meet these guys and I know you're
talking to me because I called you but
these guys that you know they didn't
call nobody they they kept it in you
know I'm proud to know that I'm a sir
with these gentlemen better in this
hotel with me after today that's cool
man i dude I love your attitude bro you
got a good attitude my life like you're
gonna do a lot of great stuff and I feel
like you know probably this experience
in there and just the boot camp and all
this it's really only gonna put you into
it's just gonna be you know such
structure and gasoline for you to really
just achieve your dreams man I just I
don't know why I get that weird feeling
but I really do bruh yeah man and um and
yeah was your wife how was that was that
it was that tough leavin he was there
you go she let me have my time yesterday
I I said goodbye to my mom my stepdad
you know rest of my family yesterday and
it was just being her today with my
daughter and she held it up until I got
on the bus and said my goodbyes ah
that's what it doesn't really when it
short me hurry and my daughter who my
daughter she spies she doesn't
understand what's going on I tell her
that hey daddy's got a new job he's
gonna be going for a while she doesn't
understand that when I say gone for a
while it's two months with just letters
no phone calls
so text messages she's wrong she's a
little girl but she's tough as [ __ ] so
they are man it'll be okay she'll be
okay for two months well man that's why
man it's powerful it's uh you know
there's a lot going on there and that's
you know even though a separation and
it's time away it's just a lot of uh you
know just seems like a lot of like
character building for all you guys even
though it's probably really tough at
this moment yes sir and at least they
have each other man that's kind of a
beautiful gift yes sir Worf of you're
from Charleston South Carolina and all
of our families still here so she's got
she's got a good support behind her yeah
and I had I have as well just not in the
physical aspect you know they're there
with me you know in spirit yeah with her
and my daughter and you know our entire
family they've been everybody's been
real supportive right
dude that's cool man well I'm excited
for your new adventure man I was
thinking um you know I was thinking of
trying to think of something nice that
we could do for you while you're this is
a ona a dream come true it is definitely
a cool experience cuz I I'm I like you
I've liked your bald white patches on it
turned me on to you with your Netflix
yeah you're desolate standup
yeah turned me on to you and oh you know
I heard you on Jill Rogan and I start
following you know this past weekend and
just you know everything comes to a head
here it is Brussels here it is man we do
to be great maybe one day in the future
you know book we can have you on as a
guest to learn a little bit more about
the military and with that boot camp
experiences like that could be really
interesting and uh but yeah I'm trying
to think you know I just really
appreciate it man I flick you you know
you seem eloquent you seem connected to
yourself I feel like you're gonna have
you know you could really gonna do a lot
of great things for your family and and
it's brave you to go in there man you're
a braver man than I for getting in there
it's just yeah you do where you from
folly or someone beat you from
technically I'd be closest to Isle of
Palms hmm that'd be the closest beach
and it's still maybe an hour away
mm-hmm well do did the cold yeah dude
look your first enemy is the cold
weather but you better [ __ ] get out
there son yes Abbi all it'll be all good
though dude you better stay there look
ya'll you ready they already got you
fighting you about to go toe-to-toe with
32° you know it was ten degrees
was the Chicago those 10 degrees well
look your first weapon to learn how to
use mittens bruh that's what it is yeah
that's cool man well and it's just so
many new experiences man its new
experiences after you're doing it sounds
like and you're making it bro you know
you're moving forward you're making
different choices man this is gonna go
by so fast and you're gonna learn so
much about yourself and I just you know
I'm envious man I feel like this is
gonna be such a neat opportunity for you
and your wife's relationship to grow
stronger and stuff and and while you're
gone man we'd love to help out dude if
it's okay with you we'd love to you know
send a gift certificate to your wife may
be a foreigner dollar gift certificate
to Target so they can just you know just
some little odds and ends here and there
while you're gone so they don't have to
think about too much extra stuff you
know well there you go boy hey man look
whatever get y'all through it brought
some how y'all met in the middle bruh
yeah that's how I was gonna say Kmart
but I didn't think I know that they've
gone out of business but what Congrats
man Congrats on your new experience bro
it's gonna be exciting and and we wish
you the best man I really appreciate you
sharing it with us and just it was nice
of you man I appreciate your nice words
and your love for your family and your
wife and your daughter just infectious
Brian thank you you know I think it
makes a lot of our listeners I just feel
the value that they have in their own in
their own in their own family so thank
you so much bro thank you yeah man and
so I'll have our producer reach out Nick
and so that we can um you know get that
to your wife and kids and a wife and
daughter and thank you for your service
you're more than welcome a member of
Gang Gang be safe out there okay peace
brother
Wow pretty cool that's brave man
that's brave you know doing something
new but he's making it you know he's
making it like it changed like you know
he just is choosing to make a change and
it'll be going it'll be it'll go so fast
and then he'll be in a new place in a
new experience and uh as brave I wish
I'd have been able to to do that I had
one more idea I was gonna do as a gift
for him but maybe we'll wait and do it
in the future if we're able to have him
in studio I think I have somebody cool
it'd be neat for him to meet but Wow you
know people are living their lives and
and that's it that's one thing about
life and destiny and that it's like no
matter you know a huge the Saints lose
and this happens and you know eleven
senior citizens died and people's you
know buying gas cans just to sneakily
get up you know it hit a blue blue chu
the Murano Dick hitters and Menino but
the truth is that life goes on the truth
is that you know those Rhino dick
hitters the truth is that life keeps
going on and that today different things
are happening and somebody's fallen in
love and somebody's you know someone is
um you know getting a phone number of
someone they've been in love with for a
while somebody is all learning how to
paint someone is going off to the
military someone's taking their last
breath somebody is on somebody's
forgiving somebody even though it's a
really hard thing to do you know you
know in my life recently I've had
something you know I've you know been
you know kind of forgiving and still
loved by somebody that I wasn't always
the best to and and when people do that
man is just a strikingly powerful
let's take another call man do should we
take another call how are we gonna go
from here anywhere we've really we've
done a lot already
homeward hey man what's up inside Joyner
Crosby I'm a kind of noodle snare - oh
the podcast down in Shelton South
Carolina
okay Jonah also in Charleston thank you
for calling brother homeward I got to
fit it out it's a great school you
should uh maybe come to a showdown that
who knows
I'd love to come to Citadel and you know
one thing that's interesting is uh now I
used to live in Charleston and I worked
on King Street and I worked at a bar and
I used to be a door boy you know out
there bouncing and [ __ ] you know just
that t-shirt that you just see the
bottom of that bicep you know and really
those guys are just a bunch of bisexuals
you know like if you see those door boys
a lot of times if you go look behind the
edge of the building at a bar you'll see
a couple of them just rubbing their
biceps against each other and that's
bisexuality and that's you know and
that's back in the day when I was doing
steroids and you know when just being
bisexual and you catch me sometimes even
at the gym just sneaking up on some of
my other man and just we [ __ ] this
rub those biceps against each other I'm
just [ __ ] bicep each other bad job
but anyhow but one interesting thing
that happens I want people to know is
the Citadel or the Citadel as people
call them different stuff because people
nobody knows how to really read or spell
that great overall and that's the truth
people are only so good at it but the
Citadel does this thing where they're
hold their hold their troops because I
believe they're a military preparatory
academy and their troops will do a march
where they go through the city of
Charleston it's really cool and they are
an organized bunch and it's really they
have these grey uniforms and and it was
really cool to see it took you back to
like a another time another time in the
world and it's a diverse group of men
and they just cruise through the street
and they're just really really awesome
it was a great it was a great thing to
witness when I was there in Charleston
was it just took you back you know a
hundred years in time onward let's take
more anyway on last weekend this dude
called him
talking about how I think it was a guy
from Charlotte talking about how it's an
issue if some girls talking to your
ex-boyfriend and I would kind of hit
close to home because one of my one of
my ex-girlfriends
uh and I have a really good like
friendly relationship like it's fully
played tonic you've both moved on we
both talk to other folks I have a
girlfriend now but uh there's nothing
wrong with it man like she and I hope
each other out if there's like something
that needs to be things to be done and
uh it's just a good friendly
relationship and I would just like to
put that out there and say that I'm not
I'm not sure what this gentleman had
experienced in his life but uh it's
really it's really not that not an issue
all the time you know what I mean you
know I appreciate that and by this
gentleman you could even mean me I think
that was my kind of my point of view you
know I thought that you know a man
doesn't keep in touch with a woman for
any real reason other than like a sexual
reason or that it's hard to really have
a platonic friendship between the two
where one doesn't have some sort of
sexual inclination or gravitas towards
the other or want to touch titty or you
know I'm saying or tap nut but yeah man
I mean you know you got me thinking
right now that maybe you're right maybe
times are changing where we are
understanding more and we also have to
go to different places to get the
emotional connection that we need
especially now that you know families
are a little bit more separated and you
know with two parents working and you
know not as much connection between a
lot of families any more relationships
and you know divorce and that sort of
thing I think yeah I think you're right
you really make me think of something
important that you know maybe now more
than ever it is it is maybe more common
to have just a friend who has of the
other sex but also dog I'll say it is
man
you know sometime you might want to [ __ ]
your friend that's the only thing you
know that's the thing that's the thing
and if you're and if you say if you have
a if you have a friend and your
girlfriend if that friend is a man then
your wife or girlfriend might not be
upset because they're not thinking then
if you guys do want to [ __ ] y'all have
to be gay for a little while you have to
be gay for a little while to do sex with
each other and you got to come back to
your spouse and not be gay so they're
thinking didn't there's at least that
and that that hurdle there that that
that that you have to that you have to
go over that ravine of choice where
you're saying okay I'm a gay out you
know I'm gonna be wild and experience
some of the things that I want to exceed
our core edges of myself or these Wilder
edges and I don't mean darker like it's
negative but these you know you you know
you only get fancy and touch and tap nut
with your buddy so you have that you
have to go through that you have to you
know just you know you have to be
bisexual brother you know what I'm
saying you have to get by sexy but but
if you if your friend is a girl than
your wife's just like oh [ __ ] man you
don't have to you know your wife already
knows that you do sex with women because
you do with her and so the fear could be
there but yeah I mean it is also a time
where we go to different places to get
different feelings where I think a lot
of needs to come straight from like the
femme you know the familial space and
I'm just guesstimating but when families
were closer and they you know needed
each other more and there wasn't as much
outside influence from the world and
technology and you know families had
farms and they needed a tenth of their
crops and do all that kind of stuff
together and you had that tribal vibe
you know as Sebastian Junger talks about
when you had that old school you got
different emotions from different places
and it was all so close together in your
source of family and now maybe you have
to go door to door these days to get the
love and affection and emotion or little
pieces of everything that you need thank
you for calling man and with that other
point of view let's take another call
here here we go
you know let's us to you um I don't even
know if I want to say my name is um I'm
in New York area what's up puppy thank
you for calling from New York man and uh
and I Love New York you know I have
dreams sometimes that if I could live
another life I would live over there in
New York somewhere you know and just
beyond just inundated with the the vibe
that's there but uh enough about me
oh my you know my my I was looking for
no inspiration you know my my cousin's
gonna prison he just went yesterday for
seven years he ought stuff
[ __ ] him me name you know we lived
amazing lifestyle you know it's this
whole chorus things it's opened up my
eyes you know makes me want to turn my
life forever you know I mean I just need
for words inspiration I really want to
do this you know what illustrating
that'll be a taxpaying citizen even
their gang good gang man man thanks for
calling man you know that's nice of you
to call bro yeah I'm sorry that you're
dealing with that I'm sorry that your
cousin is going through that I don't
know if he's you know if you're able to
talk to him I bet it's scary for him
even if he doesn't want to talk about it
or admit it you know sometime when we
when we when were tough we don't we
can't you know we can't even access the
fact that we're scared man I bet if you
could be tough and being like a
lifestyle like that I bet I bet you
could help so many younger dudes and
keep them from getting in you know in
like you know in the harm's way or but
you could help so many younger guys who
don't have like a brotherly figure you
know or who don't have like a cousin or
don't have like a male role model you
know I bet you could you know I don't
know you but I bet you could man I mean
it sounds like if you kick if you can
care about your cousin that much you
know but there's a lot of little dudes
out there who don't have that you know
or a lot of young bucks who just need
somebody you know it just sounds like
like if you can care about somebody like
him then I bet you could care about a
lot of people and it would just give you
a lot of purpose then you know there's
so much power and like helping others
and uh and you deserve a dude you know
you're good you know I don't even know
you man but I know that you're probably
a good person and I know that you know
people love you brah you know I don't
know what your family's like I don't
know if you have parents or whatever but
I'm gonna feel close with them or
whatever but I bet they really really
loved you I bet they really do even if
they can't even show you sometimes you
know I think there's this bird and that
we have as humans sometimes we're just
unable to show people that we care it's
crazy you know we have so much feelings
inside but sometimes it's so hard for it
to get out of us into and into the world
but I bet you have a lot of people that
really love you bro and
and if you you know 12-step program is
stuff that helped me dammit sorry dawn
that's your cousin's parole officer he
just got out I'm just joking bro sorry I
was [ __ ] up joke man the [ __ ] up but
I just wanted to make try and make you
laugh but yeah I mean you can you can
you know a 12-step program helped me I
didn't think there was any I didn't
think there were ways that I was ever
gonna feel better that I could change my
situation I could have a different
insight to myself dude even talking
about this stuff with you right now and
I never thought I would be [ __ ]
thinking about this kind of stuff ever
like my brain did not work this way you
know I didn't have the capacity like I
would say that I cared about myself but
I didn't ever feel it and then I got
into some 12-step and recovery help and
that [ __ ] changed my life you know and
it still changes my life and here's the
thing I haven't you made it through the
[ __ ] steps the simple fact that I
have places to go all the time where
other people who are brave enough to try
and you know take on stuff in their life
that we're there together it makes me
feel less alone you know and that must
be something you're probably feeling too
if your cousin's going away I bet you're
probably you know worried that you're
gonna be kind of a loan you know I do
you can't be alone in this place man you
go to a couple of AAA meetings see the
vibe talk to some [ __ ] bro they got
real deals in there two murderers bro
jugglers people like a [ __ ] juggle
magicians dude
dark artists do but they're all [ __ ]
now they're tightened up and it's a real
special time but look man I Love You Man
and uh and I'm sorry to hear about your
cousin and I hope that the experience
that he has in there is just is very
valuable and I hope that all you guys
the next time you guys see each other
that you're both in in much better
places and I bet that you can be I bet
you can be men it might be hard to see
that you can be but you're gonna have to
make you're gonna have to take action
you know nothing changes if nothing
changes
it just doesn't and you sound like a
powerful person so I bet you could
really affect some change in yourself
and then and then in others man and the
joy you get from that breath [ __ ] you
might turn into a rocket ship but you
might see you on Mars know you'll get
gassed up from feeling that oh you know
I'm gonna take one more call here and
and I didn't mean for this episode to be
kind of heavy or whatever but you know
we got out we got a lot of great calls
but we'll get into some more of them
let's take one right here man dang man
will it feel this is really some
Morrigan save them caps for the city I'm
watching this test weekend right now
what's up gang gang Lewis and thank you
for calling Papa homework and all I
gotta say is you give me so much
inspiration I don't know but I'm like I
have an addiction right now a cocaine
addiction
you know I 3 o'clock in the morning
oh it's 3 o'clock in the morning well
man what thanks for calling dude you
know I appreciate you calling on word I
don't have any vets but dude somebody
brought me a vest in uh in Irvine this
weekend it's a nice one too it's like a
winter time when this thing feel like
you have other vests in it like it like
like it's like a vest but it aid a
couple of little vests you know and it's
in this you know just you know have is
just warmer more yeah oh just I don't
know how'd you get over it
how'd you get over your cocaine
addiction because I look up to you man
man Gang Gang yes you go have a good day
getting gang bra yeah man look here's
the thing only you know if you have a
problem you know only you know that I
can't you know I don't know if you do uh
but you do you know if you do or not and
how I got over it I mean I'll just tap
right back into what I was talking about
it I mean I'm not over it
but I'll fight that [ __ ] you know I uh
I don't do it I haven't done it for two
and a half years and I like that dusty
dusty you know I like to [ __ ] get
that hair
dog I like that [ __ ] white semi-truck
[ __ ] driving straight to my brain you
know what I'm sayin boy Lumbee up I like
them Dark Arts at Dark Arts does daddy
sorry but I went out you did I went to a
meeting and I heard someone talk about
how they felt and why they were not
doing well and somebody told me that
then I was an okay person and then I
wasn't gonna be addicted to cocaine
forever and man I don't even know if I
was having that much of a problem with
it to be honest with you but that could
also be the addict in my head talking
but I was having a problem with myself I
was having a problem with myself when I
was there 7 a.m. you know having a
cancer whatever I supposed to do that
day and I'm just in my apartment just
like looking at pornography and you know
I can't even touch myself anymore cuz I
done touch myself you know and I got
that soft boss just laying on my stomach
and I've had that adult penis since
childhood and you know that so you know
I got that big that beached [ __ ]
armadillo just laying on my stomach and
uh and I would just be sick of myself
and I'd be afraid to go to sleep cuz I
thought I would die because I was [ __ ]
up
and I used to write wills out to my
mother I'd write a will help you know
and I'd put it by the bed in case
something happened to me because I
didn't want her you know I didn't want
to be thinking about myself when I died
you know but but I went into 12-step
meeting man I went to a couple meetings
I went to a speaker meeting they have CA
and NA meetings and and you can find
them in Oregon and we'll put the link
today on our YouTube episode to the
Oregon AAA and CA meetings there's an
app you can get on your phone I'm gonna
show it to the camera right now and it
is called meeting guide
and let me see real quick I'm gonna show
it to the phones you can get a good look
at it and this is what it looks like man
it's meeting God and we'll have my
producer Nick put it in premature Nick
and and it helps the meeting God app
just lets you know where a meeting is in
location to where you are now it doesn't
work in every city but it works in a lot
of them and and do you know what for me
I had never knew that there was a world
out there that felt more comfortable I
never knew it I didn't know it existed
man the way I related to the world was
not the way the world really was I
thought the world was a and the world
was B but I was living like it was a
imagine if you think you at the beach
but really you're downtown so imagine
you see a guy downtown and he's got on
his sandals and he's putting on
sunscreen he's putting a lawn chair out
on Sixth Avenue and you know downtown
you're like what the [ __ ] this dude's
something he doesn't get it he doesn't
realize he's not at the beach that
wasn't me I was the dude I thought I was
I thought I was at the beach but because
I thought the world was this bit but the
world was downtown the world was
something different and I was
interacting differently
and it started to change once I went to
those meetings and I just felt better
bro you know there's nothing worse than
then they come down off of cocaine and
it feels good to know that I go to bed
at night and then I'm that I know I'm
gonna wake up exactly how I went to
sleep that I know I'm will wake up
exactly how I went to sleep man for me
that's good now look if you if any but
if you still partying out there you want
to do that dust and you want to [ __ ]
let that brain don't get loose inside of
yourself
[ __ ] I'll hold the back of your neck
while you do that long line you know
I'll hold your [ __ ] back of your neck
why are you doing that for
and you know that ivory little bootie
lizard bra you know and I might be out
there again I'm not saying that I'm a
mute that I'm you know I'm human and
here we are but you can have a new
experience though I will say that man
you could have a new experience so if
you really do think you have a problem I
think it's worth checking out I will put
those links in a bio for you all right
let's do this one last call here here we
go hi my name is Tyler price I'm from
Dallas Texas I heard you guys were doing
something special for single single
mothers and Addison Texas yeah I'll be
down there this weekend Tyler I'll be
down there and the shows are sold out
down there in Addison in Dallas we're
not gonna be adding any more shows this
time but thank you very much for calling
in we argue and we're gonna be doing
something special for a single mom
what's happening cat daddy I have a
longtime friend of mine she's a friend
of mine she has three children she lives
in Madison her name is Jennifer okay you
have a longtime friend listen he said a
friend he didn't say you know and you
know somebody trying to you know you
know let their bodies pontificate each
other do that or do that touchy he said
a friend so you know there is
possibility for some friendship and
where we get it these days or sometimes
here's an example of a possibility but
anyway I don't mean to interrupt your
vibe yes we do onward one of her
children was accused of something really
serious and was recently convicted
pretty sure that that child was 13 years
old he's the oldest of her three
children she's a single mother she works
at a Firestone Oh gang man I used to put
them [ __ ] half stones on my car bro I
split the meth times in my car man
that's got to be tough tin
I bet it's tough for as a mother to see
your 13 year old Oh get caught up into
something and end up in a tough spot I
can't imagine how you navigate that
that's a that's a nice submission on
word and I
what you guys were willing to do to help
single mothers in Addison Texas but if I
know anybody that could really use the
help it would be her awesome thank you
so much for that submission and that's
really sweet of you and uh and we will
we will see what we can do for that
young lady or older I have no idea what
age he is but we will see what we can do
for her and thank you for nominating her
as always you can nominate single moms
for select cities I know that the next
one we're gonna do is uh you know hi oh
and Columbus and the number is nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three as well that is the hotline if
there's a you know if you're struggling
with something or thinking about
something you have a response to
something I've spoken about during the
podcast you can feel free to include it
there and we can't get back to all of
them we can't put all of them on the
show
there's a lot man I mean there's there's
hundreds each week hundreds each week
and uh and I want to take this moment to
to say you know I get a lot of people
that message me through different apps
on social media and I appreciate it and
that's fine and then and and some of
them I try to reply to and some of them
I can't and it's not that I don't want
to it's that if I just replied to
everyone I would uh I wouldn't have it I
would have no I wouldn't be able to eat
or drink or do anything I would have no
I just wouldn't be able to do that
because I don't have I just can't do it
I don't have the I don't hate to say I
don't have the time but I don't uh yeah
I would never I would not leave my house
because there's a lot and I'm not
bragging about that I'm just saying I
wish there was a way that I could do it
and just don't take it personally please
if I'd have been unable to do that you
know I just don't want you to think that
I don't care but man the [ __ ]
referees Brooke can you believe that
[ __ ] can you believe the
phrase you know a lot goes on in the
world man there's a big story you know
we look at the little pieces and we you
know don't get caught in that game don't
get caught in the micro man that's what
they you there's a big story you know
someone's kind of being an ass til you
ask him what hey what's going on man you
know why you having to tell what's going
on you know the only way that things
will get better I don't think the
world's a bad place the only way that it
gets better is by us we're the elements
man we're the atoms where the atoms bro
and you know unless you know we can be
on a real nucleic Rise daddy but thank
you guys for your time man I I'm gonna
give you something to eat because I
don't even eat them today but I'm
excited and thank you I'm sorry that the
episode was up late sometimes this will
occur though we had just a lot of shows
thank you everybody that came out last
weekend oh look at this new shirt you
can see it it's on the youtubes the road
to the strap goes through the rat and
this is a beautiful shirt and we're
selling this at a fair price online the
ov on.com slash store we have three new
shirts on there that are really and it
has the emblem on the back so pretty
neat man I'm happy to have when the guy
mailed me one it sounds pretty cool
thank you guys so much for everything
thank you for submitting a single mom
you know and good luck to our boy
heading out over there
and a base and basic training and just
for sharing you know an experience that
some of us didn't have you know just for
sharing it you know and for trying
something new and for being brave man we
[ __ ] you know we're we're not giving
up man we're not giving up and you know
what I got the perfect song to take us
out here from my boys down there from
Natchez Mississippi this is a different
hit of theirs and one that I really love
and one that I just think is kind of
fitting that sometime the call don't go
your way but sometime the big picture of
the story
story might be going your way you know
the game might be going your way
and we could stay out of our own way by
just going with the flow sometimes take
it easy you know know when you're you're
making [ __ ] I don't know I don't know
anything man but [ __ ] I'm sorry
sometimes I I get caught in this weird
space where I feel like I know something
but I don't and you know what I don't
really want to know anything I don't
want to know anything at all man
because I might miss the opportunity to
to learn something new you guys be good
man I love you and this is a song making
it
I ain't seen home is about a hundred
days I can almost hear mama bleep for my
restless soul and now he made a dollar
night spell but where it's going ain't
kill me and I still get when I'm down
the go
who making wrong
right
we'll hit it down bacon bits
most all of my plans slip right through
my hands and windup next to me
if they'll spiral wasn't our glance tops
way that I'm about and our cash
I'll shut about it
but how
we ride
anywhere
you
you